ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attends calme-toi attend au soir c'était
pas prévu non non non je fais visiter
les lieux alors ouais voilà parce qu'on
était à côté là on enregistre yquem seul
et je serai avec avec ramzy khiroun
alors si vous cherchez un appartient la
porte qui se libère la base d'accords
anniversaire radio autoroutière non mais
vous ne vous êtes pas de ce gâteau pour
graduer un incendie à narbonne le gâteau
nature ou la déception née muller
gaydailles bloqué ce qui se passe s'il
vous plaît rouge ou bien que nourriture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
merci à bouder et alors il vous dire que
je gêne et wild qui sont exceptionnelles
et de cas je vous offre un t-shirt
fischer allez c'est parti
voilà c'est parti la quête aka tu
rentres là dedans a laissé libre à
salaunes commerce et les chiens on vous
y attend
c'est l'anniversaire de gravure karl
zéro c'est pour toi t'as vu ce que je
fais en italie ce que je t'ai fait
tellement je t'aime ou papa je te le
gardes pour l'instant et si tu veux tu
que c'est un vrai frère c'est un vrai
gars tout frais sur la vie de ma mère ya
quoi ou à quoi bon
pourquoi je sens que koné et au chocolat
et c'est un vrai gâteau arrêté il n'y a
pas tant lui n'est sûr il graduée en
tout cas ma vocation ni telle histoire
le gers on est sûrs et oui on était sur
l'histoire de j rahim a peur mais c'est
pas pour tout le monde a peur de
personne t'arrive en place vous avez
peur sans rigoler vous avez cucquois
callejón du chocolat
on
[Applaudissements]
à